Bueno hay un poco de todo hay de esas
tecnologías un poco impresionantes hay
una moto voladora que debería ya
comenzar a funcionar a partir del
próximo año hagan de cuenta que es como
una mono cabina de un helicóptero con
unas hélices bastante grandes difíciles
de saber cómo se puede estacionar eso en
la ciudad pero es uno de los grandes
proyectos que ya están presentándose
aquí barrios barrios automóviles
eléctricos que sean de Renault pero
también de empresas
españolas y otras estadounidenses y
también hay otras aplicaciones de pronto
que nos pueden servir más para nosotros
en nuestro día a día como por ejemplo
unos stickers que se ponen sobre las
frutas o sobre las verduras para
prolongar sus vidas en la nevera por
unos cinco o diez días más o por ejemplo
los entre las startups
surcoreanas Hay cosas bastante
interesantes o bastante como decir Bueno
llamativas hay un espejo que tiene como
una especie de asistente virtual cuando
uno se está maquillando cuando uno se
está peinando y va finalmente ayudando y
guiándolo a uno en lo que debe hacer Así
que como verán hay una variedad muy
grande de aplicaciones y de diferentes
tipos de startups y de productos que se
están presentando